Hi everyone and welcome to Biology
Professor. Today we're going to be talking
about the Gram Stain procedure. The Gram Stain is a very commonly used method in
laboratory and medical settings. It is
called a differential stain, so that
means that it helps someone to
differentiate or distinguish between two
different classes of bacteria,
specifically gram positive bacteria and
gram-negative bacteria. For more
information on the differences between
those two types of bacteria, see my video
on gram positive and gram negative
bacteria. Today we're going to talk about
the steps of the Gram Stain.
It starts with heat fixing a sample. This
is when you have a biological sample
that has been heat fixed to a slide
simply by passing it over a flame. This
helps the sample containing all of the
bacteria to stick to the slide through
all the subsequent steps. The second step is the use of crystal
violet dye. This is a purple dye that
stains all of the bacteria. So you can
see here that after we use this crystal
violet dye, all of the bacteria in the
sample are going to stain purple. This is
because crystal violet dye associates
with peptidoglycan and all bacteria have
at least some peptidoglycan in their
cell walls.  Now crystal violet is a
positively (+) charged molecule and iodine
is a negatively (-) charged molecule. This
means that together they form a complex.
Iodine for this reason is called the
mordant.
It helps the crystal violet to link to
the peptidoglycan in gram positive cell
walls because they have a much thicker
layer of peptidoglycan. Then these cells,
after they've been treated with the
crystal violet primary stain and the
iodine mordant,
they are treated with a decolorizing
solution but the decolorizing solution, it
is usually some form of alcohol
that helps the crystal violet and iodine
to be washed away from cells where they
aren't very strongly adhering. These
would be the gram-negative cell walls
that only have a very, very thin layer
of peptidoglycan, leaving the
crystal violet dye and the iodine in the
gram-positive cell walls, which have that
much thicker layer of peptidoglycan. So
after using this decolorizing solution,
you have the gram positive cells still
retaining that purple crystal violet dye
and then you have gram-negative cells
that are suddenly colorless again. So
that is from the decolorizing solution.
At this point, you can visualize which
cells are gram positive because they
have retained this crystal violet dye
after using the decolorizing solution, but
then the final step is the use of a
counter stain, safranin, which has a pink
color just to help distinguish further
between those two cell types. So after
the use of safranin, crystal violet is
still in all of the gram-positive cell
walls so that these are all still purple
stained and you can distinguish that
they are gram positive, whereas the
gram-negative cell walls have taken up
this safranin counterstain making them pink.
Now at the end of a procedure like this,
you can see how it's fast, it's
inexpensive, it's relatively simple and
one of the reasons it's so useful in a
laboratory or hospital setting is it
helps to give what's called a
presumptive diagnosis.
We see that the majority of cells in the
sample are gram positive rods, so
purple gram positive rod-shaped bacteria.
The most common, or one of the most
common causes of hospital-acquired
diarrhea in adults is called
Clostridium difficile, and it is a gram
positive rod-shaped bacterium. It is the
most likely cause of the infection that
was take the sample was taken from.  And then knowing this information not only
do we have a presumptive diagnosis that
can then be confirmed through later
studies, we also know what kind of
bacteria we're working with, which helps
doctors to prescribe the correct
antibiotic regimen to treat this
infection and so this is why a Gram
Stain is so important and
this is how it works.